Bom dia good morning good morning eu já
clique em gostei Eu já queria começar
avisando a galera de Brasília dia 3 de
Junho tem show aí e o show tá [ __ ] tá 3
de junho no ginásio Nilson Nelson às 18
horas eu esperando você e toda sua
família e seus amigos chame todo mundo
que vai ser o show tá top O Show Tá [ __ ]
dos meus três show esse é o melhor e eu
quero que você confira então compre seus
ingressos ingressos no site aqui um dia
antes eu vou estar em Vitória no
Espírito Santo no Arena Vitória 21 horas
tá então conta seus ingressos também
nesse final de semana que vem agora é
Maceió Alagoas Hum pertinho de olho eu
casei Arapiraca Alagoas e Natal Rio
Grande do Norte hein lá no partage Norte
Shopping Vai ser top como seus ingressos
Aqui estamos juntos é nós vamos ao vídeo
eu acabei de acordar e acordei muito
feliz porque você acordou muito feliz eu
acordei muito feliz porque dormir muito
bem isso quando tu vai crescer né raro
dormir bem É raro Porque quanto mais tu
cresce tu vai perdendo qualidade de sono
para criança criança tem um sono mais
top que existe no mundo Criança dorme em
qualquer lugar meu irmão porque ela
gasta energia o dia inteiro não tem nada
para fazer não tem preocupação ela corre
corre corre corre
ai ai ai ai ai ai
ai como ela não tem preocupação nenhuma
quando eles gotas de energia ela dorme
em qualquer lugar
[Aplausos]
dorme em qualquer lugar Você já viram
criança dormindo na mesa do restaurante
mas homem em qualquer lugar que você
botar ela dentro de uma panela Ela dorme
enquanto vai crescendo aí dando um bug
que tu não consegue controlar mais tá
insônia você simplesmente fica acordado
do nada igual um parasita tá com sono e
não consegue dormir eu tenho raiva disso
eu tenho raiva até de quem chama Sony tu
vai crescendo Para tu dormir é a cama é
cheia de código é um travesseiro aqui do
lado não porque a minha lombar tá com
criança nem sabe o que é lombar assistir
filme de madrugada quando eu era criança
Ave Maria meu amigo tu é doido era maior
dificuldade que tinha eu botava era que
eu falava hoje eu não sou é macho quero
ficar acordado até horas da noite para
assistir Matrix que vai passar 11:30 da
noite eu não me chamo Whindersson se eu
não ficar acordado até 11:30 da noite
hoje eu quero é ver quem vai fazer eu
dormir ia pra sala sentava no sofá hoje
eu vou assistir esse filme botava na
novela fala vou esperar juro por Deus 9
horas da noite eu tava parecendo aqueles
cara da Nasa que faz teste da força
gente fica assim ó para não fechar o
olho para não dormir só assim ó
eu fui só piscar cara eu queria só
piscar eu pisquei quando eu abri meu
olho tava no Globo Rural
não tem dinheiro não
mãe porque a senhora me acordou mãe eu
falei que eu queria assistir uma atriz e
eu fiquei zangado adora comigo era com a
minha mãe não me acordou para assistir
Matrix e nesse ano eu já tinha falhado e
assistir filme 11:30 da noite 30 vezes
não foi a primeira vez não que eu tentei
mas ali era quando eu tinha um sono top
hoje eu tenho que me preocupar eu não
assisti todos os filmes e série do mundo
que eu boto aqui para assistir Major
acabou eu não sinto sono eu botei que
tome ela la casa de papel la casa de
cartolina la casa de papelão por causa
do que tiver qualquer casa que tiver
Seja lá de que ela foi feita eu assisto
a Luísa chega pergunta vai dormir não eu
digo o quê Vai dormir tu vai dormir não
eu quis dormir rapaz dormir ah dormir
aquele negócio que fechou Eita tá sonha
as coisas Ah não não quero não esqueci
como é que dorme acorda eu já acordou
assim que eu tenho coisa para fazer
responsabilidade aí com raiva já acordo
com raiva eu tô aqui dormindo
graça tchau
que eu já sei o que é que eu vou fazer
criança tem um sono pesado pesado que
Ave Maria como a criança não tem nada
para fazer ela acorda parece que ela tá
acordada em outro mundo tudo para ela é
novo isso é uma criança quando acorda
assim ó
cadê mãe a pergunta logo pela mãe que é
quem a pessoa que bota comida na boca
dela que é isso que ela faz gasta
energia dorme acorda alguém recarrega
ela gasta energia dorme acorda alguém
recarrega ela quando você cresce ninguém
te recarrega mais então se você não
fizer você morre a criança vem de outro
tempo o espaço ali a gente acorda já
puto que já sabe as coisas tem que fazer
é criança não criança ela acorda assim a
conta até acorda falando as falas do
sonho que ela tá confundindo ela não
sabe se ela acordou ainda Bora acorda
pra ir pra escola não foi eu não é por
causa do Maicon bora acordar Ei pra
escola e aí que arrancou o negócio das
costas do Dragão mãe foi meu filho foi
levanta vem nós escovar os dentes vem
vai dormir de novo não vem embora sonho
Ave Maria eu nem conto meu sonho eu só
sei besteira eu só sonho coisa nada a
ver não tem pé nem cabeça nada zero eu
acho chique demais as pessoas me
contando o sonho gente Ontem eu sonhei
acredita que eu sonhei que eu tava de
carro e eu fui até o o supermercado
comprei um pouco de cuscuz Eu fiz um
jantar para toda a família um prato
lindo cuscuz com salgadinho do lado
aquelas coisas sensacionais Jantamos
todos em comunhão aí eu acordei Meu
sonho não tem pé nem cabeça eu sonhei
aqui eu tô conversando com a pessoa aqui
a Luísa falou ô Luiza tudo bom como é
que tá aqui responde do gato ali já é
meu pai fala tô tô bom Aí eu ah estamos
aqui né bem no campo aqui que Campo
Bonito né eu viro as costas não é Campo
mais é uma montanha aí eu pulo da
montanha eu vou eu falo [ __ ] meu
irmão eu vou quando eu percebo que eu
vou eu não vou mais eu já Caio e tento
voar e não consigo de novo do nada vem
um dragão gigante pouso no meu ombro
porque o Dragão Gigante pequeno ele
gigante para outras coisas Eita dragão
hein será que solta fogo ele solta água
pela boca minha mãe aparece a minha mãe
até a metade de baixo para baixo é o
cavalo ela é um Centauro uma camisa do
Brasil joga bola é jogador de futebol
Centauro eu olho para a mãe e fala mãe
Carai só tá muito diferente ela fala não
aqui é porque eu tava quando pegando um
negócio do Maicon falei o quê não porque
o carro que ele arrancou o negócio da
Costa do Dragão aí eu acordo Ah o
pessoal fala tu sonhou o quê eu digo
nada porque se eu conto isso aí a pessoa
vai falar meu Deus mongolóide Jesus o
céu chegou um sonho desse pra falar com
aquelas pessoas de significado do sonho
o que é que significa meu sonho ela fala
aí é morrer aí vai morrer certeza
absoluta você já sonharam que estão nu
[ __ ] meu Deus que agonia Jesus eu já
sei o que eu tava tocando tipo num Rock
in Rio assim na hora que eu comecei a
tocar não tava mas do nada virou Rock in
Rio porque meu sonho e do nada eu tô
pelado e todo mundo olhando pra mim Ah e
eu não sei se o povo estava falando Ah
Rock and vai peladão meu Deus alguém me
ajuda mãe Lavei minha mãe
falei mãe por que que eu tô pelada Ela
falou não é porque por causa do negócio
lá do Maicon falei [ __ ] de novo aí
acordei agora eu vou contar meu sonho
para você meu sonho era acordar igual
aquelas pessoas de filme que acordado
sabe com uma mensagem que ela recebeu no
sonho
aí a mulher tá do lado
foi só um sonho querida
volte a dormir foi uma mensagem ele tá
vindo atrás de mim
eu acho chique demais acordado desse
jeito eu não acordo assim não eu acordo
com o espasmo espasmo minha coisa mais
ridícula que você pode fazer perto de
algum outra pessoa não tem nada mais
ridículo cair você se explica pô cai
espasmo não tá quase dormindo acontece
isso
ridículo ridículo odeio eu tô com esses
problemas de dormir eu tenho raiva
porque eu amo dormir cara eu acordo que
eu mais gosto de dormir toda vez que eu
vou dormir alguém quer fazer suco e não
é disso aqui não porque todo dia faz
suco de saquinho bota no copo bota as
coisas aqui povo bebe no dia que eu vou
dormir aí eu quero suco de frutas no
liquidificadores tô pegando no sono
rapaz ninguém dorme nessa casa não cara
querer dormir rapaz tô fazendo suco
sequei ai faz o suco toma e nem me dá um
pouquinho me acordou e não me dá Ei
enquanto dorme por cima do braço e dá
câimbra coisa estranha da [ __ ] do
parece que é um braço 10 vezes maior do
que eu tenho dorme aqui ó por cima do
braço assim aí tu acorda de noite tu
pega na tua mão parece que tá pegando
uma mão de um cara muito grande cara
Teve um dia que eu acordei de noite que
eu peguei na minha mão parecia tanto a
mão de outra pessoa que eu falei Boa
noite eu juro por Deus então é isso se
você gostou do vídeo clique em gostei
aqui cara isso ajuda demais a gente você
que é de Brasília não esquece dia 3 de
junho no ginásio Nilson Nelson às 18
horas tá ingressos na central de
ingressos do Brasília Shopping Vitória
no Espírito Santo é dia 2 de junho o
local é Arena Vitória 21 horas compre
seus ingressos dia 25 de Maio 25 agora
eu tô em Maceió ali pertinho de onde eu
casei tá no ginásio do Sesi às 20 horas
tá então chama os seus amigos dia 27 de
maio eu tô em Natal no partage Norte
Shopping tá compre seus ingressos no
site tem vários outros show lá pra você
ver tá então tamo junto é nós Espero que
você tenha gostado e Berg
valeu